the inspiration for this talk is there's
a designer that I followed named Brad
Frost and he wrote a post last year
actually called why I'm not a JavaScript
developer and he basically took a list
of front-end interview questions
specific to drop a JavaScript that is on
the html5 boilerplate github and he sort
of took every question and wrote kind of
a smartass remark to it so for instance
he said why is it called a ternary
expression what does the word ternary
indicate ternary means it involves three
things and strings them all on one line
so it's harder to read and then he said
create a loop so this is the the
fizzbuzz question create a loop that
iterates up to 100 while outputting fizz
and multiples of 3 buzz at multiples of
5 and fizzbuzz at multiples of 3 and 5
so this is a actual kind of standard
coding question and his response was
that sounds hard and for some strange
reason I am suddenly jonesing for dr.
pepper and so it was funny I read it and
I was like oh yeah that's that's funny
but it was like he was funny but then I
thought I I don't know that I could
answer those questions like I use
JavaScript every day
and I build software with it but I these
seem kind of basic and I don't know the
answer to them so and I figured that I'm
probably not alone in that like you can
actually build a lot of awesome stuff
with the tools that you use and not
completely understand the tools
themselves so I took thought a good talk
idea was to take some of these questions
and just try and answer them and answer
them like succinctly as if I would have
to be in an interview and maybe give
some real-world application to them but
before I jump into the questions
themselves you kind of want to address
the point of like our interview
questions are they a are they a good
idea I I think that this is definitely
something and if you're a junior
developer and you're gonna be you're
going to be going to a lot of interviews
and you're gonna probably doing a lot of
code tests and things like that
or if you're a hiring manager looking at
it from the other way you should know
that a lot of times putting people on
the spot with things like this is
essentially creating a adversarial
relationship with the person that you're
interviewing and that really may not not
be what you want to do you might want to
be in a position where you want a person
to feel comfortable with your company
with your team so I'm not necessarily a
proponent of asking a bunch of arbitrary
code questions in interviews but I
figured it doesn't hurt to know the
answers so let's get started we'll start
with this one is kind of a softball and
I guess I'll preface this by saying if
your senior dev in here you're probably
this is old old turf for you but
hopefully maybe there's some new things
that you hadn't ever known exactly how
it works
I learned something this morning just
from researching this and if you are a
junior or beginner hopefully this will
sort of answer a couple questions for
you but this one is pretty basic but it
was one that I couldn't succinctly
answer explain event delegation event
delegation is JavaScript as it relates
to the Dom it basically means that if
you attach an event listener to Dom
element that listener is not only firing
on that Dom element it's actually firing
on every children in that so for
instance if you have a navigation and so
you've got an unordered list and you've
got list items and then you've got
anchor tags inside that navigation what
you have if you add an event listener to
the UL in essence you're actually adding
event listeners to all of the children
as well so it's something to and this
happens through a process called event
bubbling so sort of the inverse of the
idea of delegating down bubbling is when
it comes back up so events on an element
will bubble up to all of their parents
so when you click on that a you're
actually clicking on the Li and you're
clicking on the UL and you're clicking
on the body ultimately so that that's
the concept of even
bubbling so how it actually works out in
practice ways that I found it useful are
for instance if you have live edits to a
form that you want to track and you've
got a form with a group of inputs in
here I may have to go them over here to
scroll yeah but you've got all different
types of inputs and you want to maybe
test when they blur out of one of these
inputs or they key up or something like
that well you could go through and you
could target each one of these
individually you could grab all of them
by a specific tag and then you could do
this the special loop over them in order
to add an event listener to every single
one so that would totally work and then
you'd have one function that would you
would probably have to create a
different case for what type of thing it
is in there but you can bind to it but
you can also just simply bind to the
parent so just grab the form itself and
everything inside of it that can change
that can fire a change event is going to
fire a change event and so your form
would run and then in here you might
have some sort of switch based on the
name of that element or something like
that and this kind of demonstrates for
us this was a part of the the questions
but it's sort of a bonus tip bit you'll
notice that when I'm listening to kind
of a more Universal event on looking for
child elements that would trigger it I
want to use event target not event
current target and so that's a bonus
little tidbit that the difference
between target and and current target
whenever on an event listener is that
target is the actual thing that was
clicked
whereas current target is what you
attach the event listener to so if
you've ever wondered what that is I had
to answer that question like just last
week so so that's that's a little bit
about the Dom moving on next question
explain why the following doesn't work
as
if be well in order to answer that I
actually didn't know what an if he was
so what is an iffy if he stands for
immediately invoked function expression
so if you actually ran this code the way
that it looks right now you would get a
syntax error in your browser and what
you would want to do is basically it's
the idea of an immediately invoked
function expression is basically I write
this function and I run it I just want
to write it and then run it immediately
but you can't do it this way and the
reason why is has to do with kind of
another related question is the
difference between writing a function as
a statement or as a definition and
writing it as an expression so in
JavaScript anytime we there are sort of
you have statements and you have
expressions expressions result in a
value and that's the concept of an
expression so if you like assign a
variable and try to attach a value to it
that will be read and interpreted as an
expression and it will create a value
this creates more of sort of like a
reference but it's not an actual value
so you can't just run it in fact if you
sort of try to run this code immediately
this is how javascript is reading it and
it's like this doesn't make any sense to
me
you wrote this thing and then later on
you're trying to call a function that
you doesn't have a name this this is
weird so instead you need to but there
are a lot of benefits and I'll call and
get into the benefits of the second of
writing it this way how can I write it
that way and get it to run immediately
well you can make that function at an
expression simply by putting parentheses
around it so now that this is in
parentheses JavaScript is going to
interpret whatever is inside that
parentheses to be an expression not to
be a statement
and then it can run immediately so this
is called an immediately invoked
function expression so I guess that begs
the question like why why would I
actually need to use this well in a lot
of situations and and this is probably
if you're working within a framework or
something like that you may not need to
like you may never end up in this
situation but the next time that
somebody asks you to build like them a
simple webpage then this is going to be
relevant again you do it in order to
control variable scope so if you wrote
this function that function is not going
to be available the variables inside
that are not going to be available
outside of that function and actually
the guy who's Josh Mach is speaking
right after me he wrote sort of the best
blog post that I found on this concept
and of like why you might want to
control that scope and it used to be I
think for software developers it used to
be more of an issue because we were
writing a lot of things with jQuery and
there were a million jQuery plugins that
could be in our application and they all
had very dumb and plain naming
conventions and I was like I want to use
dumb and complain naming conventions in
my application so so this is how you do
it
and it kind of relates to another
question on this list is that why in
general is it a good idea to leave the
global scope audible website and not
touch it and it's because you can't
predict the future so 27 years ago
Robert Zemeckis predicted that the Cubs
would win the World Series in 2015 and
boy was he wrong he was a year off what
an idiot but seriously like you don't
know especially if you're building that
that web page for your friend like what
they're gonna want to put pull in what
kind of libraries and you want to
control your variable names so you never
have collision within your scope it also
allows you to maintain independence and
it makes it easier to write your own
code you call things whatever you want
because it's all
contain so that's a little bit about
scope kind of adding on to that concept
is this word which is probably my
favorite javascript word which is
hoisting explain hosting and before I
wrote this talk I actually had no idea
like what this was it I had observed it
but I had never quite understood it it
means that all variables that are
declared using var so this was kind of a
specific problem I'll get into how it's
been addressed a little bit but all
variables using four are declared at the
top of any given function scope whether
you really know it or not whether you
sort of like it enough or not and this
actually includes the functions that are
written as statements hold on where were
they so the top example this would
include those as well those are hoisted
so this is kind of an example of what
you might see but this is I used to try
and do this all the time I would say
okay I've got a variable and under this
condition I want that variable to be
this and in this other condition I want
the variable to be this and I would just
just be like well I haven't like create
this variable anymore I'll create it
here and then and here I'll create it
and then maybe I have another case where
I don't need to create the variable yeah
I've saved memory or something thought
about myself in my head but if you use a
linter or something like this you will
probably notice that this chokes this
does not like you to write it like this
it would say something like action is
already defined on line six because this
is in reality what is a happening behind
the scenes that you don't even know
about but javascript is taking that var
and it is creating var action up here at
the top and then what it's seeing
here is that you're trying to declare
this variable that's already been
declared not only are you signing it a
value again but you're declaring it
again and it's like this is what are you
doing this is what javascript is
actually doing to your code if you write
functions as statements like this those
functions are actually all being hoisted
to the top the entire function this is
sort of why and I had never really
understood this but sometimes I would
write a function and I would try and
call it and it would say that it was
undefined but then I would move it in
another place in the code and it would
work but then other functions didn't
seem to work that way well it all boils
down to whether you write them as
statements or assign them to variables
so so yeah Lehner's will kind of bark at
you about this because it's sort of not
clean code and it's but it actually
works in the browser browser hasn't had
no problem with it
but it means what hoisting means is that
technically this works you can have your
whole if statement you can assign value
to it assign a different value and then
declare it further on down in the code
and this is totally fine for JavaScript
and actually in the browser so this is
this is pretty absurd this is one of the
reasons why like people say that they
hate JavaScript and whatever and we have
a bad reputation whatever so in walk
this has kind of been addressed with es6
and the idea of constant and lead so
constant and let are ways of assigning
variables that are not wasted they are
actually even more than scoped within
the function that you're in they're
scoped within the block that you're in
so if you're just in this in this if
statement you can have variables that
are scoped within there that the outside
part of the function will have no
knowledge of I would say that that this
makes more sense like the more that I
develop of wanting to control this kind
of initially I was like everything can
know about everything I don't care but
this is really
for kind of performance and things like
that to scope things as closely to where
you want to use it as possible and it
sort of gives you more control and again
like I mean your colleagues might not
like you but if you want to use like VAR
x equals this and VAR y equals that you
can and you can use it all over there's
a really good article about it by a
German doctor axel rothmeyer about this
variables in scoping in es6 I would
highly recommend checking it out so I
guess the question is sort of after
knowing these things what do we do with
the knowledge of hoisting like does it
actually change the way that we write
our code and I'm really I'm not gonna
touch this one this is like I think that
this has been pretty well argued ever
since constant and let came out of like
which ones you should use but I do see a
value in and declaring things as closely
to where you're going to use them and I
think part of my original intention here
this is what I learned about hoisting
was hosting constant and let give you
block scoped variables and hoisting was
basically trying to fake that the whole
time so constant and let are basically
solving the problem that's existed in
JavaScript of we want to do this and we
can't so we use hoisting to sort of fake
it so I'll probably be writing constant
and let mostly but so speaking of I've
used the word declare a lot there's
another question of like the what is the
difference between a variable that is no
undefined or undeclared so we'll start
with undeclared it is not simply a short
live show on Fox anybody ever see
undeclared yeah if you like freaks and
geeks
you might check out undeclared it's not
as
good but you know so undeclared is
basically when you try and use a
variable that that you've never sort of
used before you've never written out far
foo equals or Const foo equals but you
try and use it in some kind of manner so
that's a pretty simple concept of what
is undeclared it's just you you forgot
something somewhere or you ripped out
some code in my case you ripped out some
of your co-workers code and now it's not
working
so that's undeclared undefined is it's a
little bit different undefined means
that you have declared it but it doesn't
have a value it has not been a sign of
value so these are all up here at the
top are all kind of examples of ways
that you might get undefined so if you
just declare a variable don't assign a
value if you have an empty object or you
try and grab something on an object and
it's not there you'll see undefined same
goes for like the index of an array
nothing is there or if you run a
function and the function doesn't return
anything so that which is totally fine
to do undefined is not it's not always
undeclared is sort of something's gone
wrong but undefined you could get for
all kinds of reasons though it's not
necessarily an indicator that something
that's gone wrong the cool thing is with
constant is that you can only use
constant whoa look at that you are
forced with constant to assign a value
to it whenever you declare so that may
change actually the way that you want to
use things because in a lot of
situations I don't want to do that I
want it to create a variable and then
have it change depending on situations
so but that that is kind of nice because
you'll never sort of have the problem of
being undefined and then you have oh
yeah I've got this whole list of
important information
oh it's also false see which kind of
plays into that it's not necessarily an
indicator that something is wrong you
can definitely use it if in some kind of
logic condition if you're looking for
false ii know is a little bit different
and like it's kind of nuanced but knoll
is a value it's just not a value you
know no is actually the interpreted as
having a value that value is not it's a
nothing value it's a way of sort of
creating in a placeholder assignment for
something that would have maybe other
values you see this all the time
especially like if you're dealing with
an api you you might have something on
an object that's returned from your api
you might see the key there and the keys
value is null and that's that's
completely right and if you ever have a
situation where you need to sort of zero
out of value null is a great tool in
order to do that because because the
idea of zero as a number well that's
actually a value or zero as a string
well that's certainly a value so you can
use null instead yeah look through my
notes here so finally what the question
is if you how do you go about checking
for any of these states well the first
one is kind of easy undeclared will
usually find you I say usually but it
doesn't always find you because if
you're trying to assign a value to a
variable that hasn't been declared
javascript will totally let you do that
and it will go ahead and attach that
value to the global scope which is
really bad so essentially all that stuff
that I talked to
about not touching the global scope
javascript will let you just do that if
you leave off the the word bar so be
careful use a linter that's what I would
advise for there and this is another one
of the reasons why people hate
JavaScript about whatever haters now if
you want to check for undefined this
also kind of sucks because if you check
you can use type of it's really handy to
check for like if it's a number or if
it's a string or whatever if you try and
do use type of it will return undefined
as a string which is like frustrating
because all of a sudden we're dealing
with like this information that is in a
different type than what it actually is
so you can't use type of this inequality
checks because you've got this word
undefined as a string undeclared
variables will also return undefined if
you try and type of them now I'm
beginning to see why people hate
JavaScript and if you so the preferred
method would be to use a triple equals
to check if something is undefined and
not not not in this string by the way
even though that doesn't make any sense
because but yeah anyway so because if
you look for undefined as a string and
check it against undefined even though
this is what the console spits out it
will fail so yes check for undefined
with triple equals and the reserved word
undefined with null type of null
actually returns an object it will say
that you have an object this is a bug in
JavaScript this is a literal bug in
JavaScript that they are not fixing
because they have higher priorities and
by they I mean me because it's a
community like it's all falls on our so
all of our shoulders
so but you can also use the triple
equals with the reserved word null in
order to check for null and then finally
like this triple equals thing is just
it's always a great question but what is
the difference between double equals and
triple equals and so here's an example
foods undefined bar is null and food
double equals bar is true yeah and that
makes sense
essentially the what you have when you
use double equals is a check for
equality and JavaScript sees null and
undefined as both sort of having no
value and and says that those are equal
even though they are not the same type
of thing so triple equals is always
gonna check for equality and type and if
anybody here is like done any sort of
like recent learning I'm gonna everybody
loves audience participation right how
many people have been told
always use triple equals no matter what
you've been lied to
been lied to people the reason people
tell you that is because they don't
think you're smart enough to understand
it and use it correctly but you can
absolutely use this correctly and if you
know what you're doing and you want to
use the double equals go ahead and use
it and put a little comma above it for
the rest of your developers to like not
go in and change your PR or be mad at
you because you know what you're doing
so that's pretty much it I'm gonna I'm
gonna skip the event loop because it
really deserves its own talk I just had
it in there because I thought that yeah
never mind I knew I was not gonna have
time for that but just in case so anyway
you guys since you're at this talk you
were hired hopefully you get a boss just
as fun as Kimmy Schmidt's boss
wherever you go to work and there are a
ton more of these up on html5
boilerplate I it was a fun exercise for
me to just go through these and be like
which of these can I not answer quickly
cannot answer well but I just want to
sort of say at the end of this talk I
I've been doing this for about five
years and I've am now sort of like the
senior guy on my team and everything
else but it doesn't really it doesn't
really account for a whole lot
necessarily that you can answer these
questions like super well my
encouragement to anybody at this
conference who's sort of like me feeling
really overwhelmed and really like I
just don't know how I'm gonna actually
apply this to my application coming the
next day I just really encourage you
just keep moving forward
building whatever it is that you're
building just build good software I
think a lot of times as developers we
focus on the tools that we're using the
best way to use those tools the most
efficient way which I totally get and
it'll totally love to do but we lose
sort of focus on like that we're here
we're getting paid to deliver badass
software and if we just focus on that
then the tools were used in the
decisions and the learning it's gonna
come alongside that and happen as well
we don't have to like learn all this
stuff first and have all these perfect
answers or even really know the perfect
terminology for what it is that we're
doing in order to make awesome software
and I am a pretty good example of that
because I won't say that I can make
software without knowing whatever it is
that I'm doing so
anyway that's that's the talk the slides
are up on my website